foreign
folks we might be drunk here we are a
little snafu Sam is aged and became a
non-jew
you got good yeah oh you're a half yeah
whoa whoa
all right well is it Dad
's Jewish they don't count that man they
don't count it just as Jewish as you are
to them all right damn sorry I I like a
little bit did you have to do the the
bar mitzvah and all that damn to my
cousins yeah okay yeah because you
couldn't be more Gentile you think so I
mean Midwest honky wrestler cauliflower
ear
uh happy you know fun loving cool guy
yeah you're a boy okay all right but you
know you've got your St Louis [__] on
yeah yeah man yeah you got to represent
we got Jews in St Louis oh you do yeah
not a lot but there's a district you
know oh yeah the Jew area yeah yeah I'm
from New Orleans we got a just a tiny
little sect and it's it's like this
beautiful neighborhood and they have a
beautiful school and uh everybody wants
to get in
same with St Louis it's nice yeah
they're killing it those Jews yeah they
really do it it throws it [__] up the
whole minority uh argument because it's
like we were marginalized and kicked out
and oppressed and here we are killing it
yeah and that's why everybody hates them
I don't know if the Orthodox really uh
they're not helping the cause yeah that
I I uh that's when I lived here was when
I had the first interaction with the
Orthodox Jews and it was the same
interesting yeah I think my favorite
thing was I was like uh walking in uh
Brooklyn one time and there's they were
in the what's the whatever they wear oh
yeah like the black the black yeah the
suits and yeah there they are three of
those guys and they were uh they were
playing basketball what yeah yeah in
this like park in Brooklyn and uh
and they they sucked like that they were
they were backing yeah yeah there was no
dog it was the first time in my I'm
terrible at basketball the first time I
was like I could take these guys
damn did you have to help him shoot
because it was Saturday yeah throw the
ball for him I can't touch the ball
yeah my uh my fourth first uh
interaction with Orthodox was here as
well I lived in Brooklyn in Crown
Heights which is a Jewish neighborhood
and uh I'd get drunk and come home at
like four in the morning and they'd be
driving around in minivans doing who
knows what and they would go you're on
the you're on the wrong side you get in
the van they thought I was Jewish really
there you go I'm not Jewish they would
slide that door closed peel out of there
yeah that was it was ugly over there
look at that there they go I see that's
how much fun that is man they're having
a good time they're all dressed the same
though that would annoy me you want to
have a little bit of your own
individuality I bet you there's a flare
of some like a cufflink or something uh
yeah I don't know maybe like a Yankees
yamaka something making your own a
shoelace of some sort or uh you know
yeah yeah not seeing it but I bet you
there's something it was also fun too
because uh my landlord was Jewish
are you guys sitting down landlord's
Jewish but he uh he couldn't talk to my
girlfriend at the time because they're
not allowed to talk to strange women
yeah and uh so he'd come into my house
because I was like oh the pipes bursts
and he'd be like okay and they could
it's funny seeing an orthodox guy with a
tool belt first of all and he would come
in and she'd be like yeah it's the one
and he's like
and I was like that's pretty good so I
started doing it to her so I would you
know come home the next day and she's
like you didn't answer but
a woman woman she hated it but we had a
good time I had the same like uh when I
lived down the Lower East Side my
neighbors were Muslim you know yeah and
uh
Muslim women are not supposed to make
eye contact with with unfamiliar men oh
really yeah so we would pass pass in the
hallway and she wouldn't look at me but
I mean
you know like she she really wouldn't
look at me like she oh yeah yeah like
she yeah she gave it a little bit I
think it was her way of saying hey even
if I wasn't Muslim
you still have no chance
yeah damn that sucks because all they
have is the eyes right I mean she had a
burka on I assume yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so there's nowhere else to look I
think I saw I think I saw maybe more
than I should have oh like nothing you
know like a hair wisp yeah I think I saw
at some point because you know you live
in the same area there's gonna be
everybody has a bad day sure sure well
they they must uh you guys can relate on
the bombing all right but
oh wait a minute I think that was like
they bomb you stand up I stand up all
the time I was slow on that yeah that
was a bomb yeah man no I bombed Plenty
when I was living here yeah yeah we all
did yeah but uh yeah yeah the Muslim
thing that's tough you know you can't I
do you think there must be some fantasy
like you're this this cracker coming
through the hallway and she's it's so
forbidden that she must wanna go down on
you man I gotta tell you I like I didn't
pick up on any fantasy okay yeah yeah I
I it was quite the opposite all right I
mean yeah I don't think there was that
going on oh okay I would I'd like to
believe that now yeah maybe I'm
projecting because I thought it about
them and there's porn of his Muslim porn
uh with these women and they'll like
take their burqa off and start blowing a
bunch of dudes what oh it's hot but I
think they're banned from their country
now are they actors well they're porn
actors what I mean are they uh real
Muslim women well they're Middle Eastern
but I don't know if they're actually
Muslim I'd probably not but the the
Muslim uh you know the Empire what do
you got a president I think that's a
solid they hate it yeah
uh no Shaw's uh Persian Imam Imam Imam
yeah Imam they're the religious leaders
like priests or whatever okay they don't
like it they don't like the porn I would
say most of them yeah yeah don't care
for it I don't think they care for the
gays either no they have a penalty for
homosexuality in Afghanistan where they
push a wall on you what a giant wall on
you and if you survive you can continue
to live but if you die you die die wait
a minute the punishment for
homosexuality they take a wall straight
up wall just a wall like this a brick
wall and they push it on you it's brick
though yeah oh no it's it's uh cinder
block
whoa wow can I do my act in front of it
I'm used to being my brick walls yeah
wow smushing a wall
wow what is that gonna do if he survives
he's still gay
it's a horrible I don't think so man
you think it pushes it out yeah yeah I
think it's uh yeah
damn not outwardly I would say hey look
we have conversion therapy here which
you know is obviously crazy but it ain't
no wall we're doing better we're
Progressive yeah yeah balls don't work
oh tell that to China
Great Wall big wall there big wall Great
Wall I wonder if they got [__] for
building that wall you know people like
this [__] president he's a oh yeah
he's a racist were they keeping any I'm
sure was it the Mongols or something
they were keeping out yeah that was
their Mexicans also apparently it's
built without any right angles if you
notice this wavy like this because
Spirits can pass through right angle
walls but they can't pass through a wall
like this Ah that's convenient wow what
what [__] came up with that you know
he's like now we gotta curve the wall
because here dumb ideology yeah can you
think of the bricklayers that we're
dealing with oh my God
have you been to the wall
the Great Wall uh no I've been to the
gay thing but uh
however I forgot you went there on
spring break yeah yeah that's fun yeah
no they put me in front of it do you
think they call the wall the grinder
all right
sorry but
I've been to the Great Wall of China and
it's [__] amazing it's like it's
incredible they built it that big back
then just guys putting Stones no
Machinery no Bobcat no bulldoze just
hand on hand action insane and you can
see it from outer space is that true or
is that a is that a thing I think that's
true yeah or is that an old man I think
I've seen both sides of that where it's
like it's true and then I was like yeah
you really can't oh wait a minute yeah
pulse here oh [__] there it is there it
is there walked on that you
uh oh here we go MythBusters coming at
you
jerks ruin a lot of fun didn't they they
really did those MythBusters damn pop
rocks and soda won't kill you apparently
okay so hey
girl we've been replaced by the Gentiles
no I mean you guys could switch and swap
switch and swap there we go
to see you hey all right oh yeah that
really I really picked the wrong shirt
to come in a cranky mood today
this is a meltdown in on the subway it
wouldn't move Mark has a Subway story
from today as well the trainers wouldn't
move I was stuck first you know I'm
never late I'm usually like 15 early I
like to have punctuality is important to
me yeah it was the uh for the c or the N
oh interesting okay what happened to you
I saw I was on the uh the sea and a guy
had a knife and the cops were like put
it down put it down brah so I jumped on
the a damn that really pisses me he took
all my thunder no
tell your little a Subway story yeah was
there a knife was it a knife well there
we were
sitting there we weren't moving at all
no that's crazy a knife yeah yeah well
it wasn't that crazy because the cops
were terrified they had hands on the
guns but the guy goes just take it take
the knife and he just dropped it were
there any Marines on board
no too soon too soon I liked it all
right uh do we have a bartender today no
what would you like I need something
after that yeah 15 minutes of waiting
get the man about egg and soda all right
I'll do a yeah I'll do something good
dude by the way the special is amazing
oh thanks man yeah you're such a great
comic watch Greg Warren's new special uh
it's their second Nate land produced
special oh yeah it was Mike in here yeah
Mike's off Mike's was so good man I
loved it I watched it when they
premiered it it was it was so great so
so many just good it's just so tight
yeah special oh thanks buddy thanks I
really appreciate you watching it man so
good and also Freddie Demarco is a dude
oh yeah man that's so cool here's a
story about a guy Freddie DeMarco who I
met in Missouri oh this goes into a
Mizzou game yeah this goes way back
because Sam I think it was like early in
your career yeah and you were like hey
man I'm doing Conan and I really don't
have any clubs to go I want to promote a
club and I just I know I'm real close to
that club yeah so I called him and I was
like hey get get Sam and they were like
yeah yeah you know they knew who you
were they were like yeah yeah so Sam
goes there and he calls me he's like is
there anything I should do when I'm in a
college town I'm like well have you ever
been to a college football game like a
big college he's like no so Freddy's
this guy that um used to own the club
and he took Fred he took Sam doing he's
a character man hell yeah Carrick
Italian guy like that lives in the
middle of Missouri instead man Craig
what are you doing man you're busting my
he loves Sam too man yeah he knew
exactly I was like hey this guy Sam I
know that guy man real funny man they're
real dark man but I love this game man
yeah tell them I'll take them to a game
man hell yeah yeah the story yeah the
stories in the special are so good man
it's just like out of the gate like I
love when in the first minute and a half
it's just like bam bam bam yeah is your
is your white knight that's not St Louis
is it that was Cleveland Cleveland okay
yeah yeah St Louis is a wild town man
first of all that that funny bone there
oh yeah bananas well there used to be
that the other one too next to the bird
and the gun store oh that I never even
work yeah Valley Park that did that was
like my whole time in New York so I
never worked it barely ever went there
now there's another one but it's in a
different area it's kind of nice oh yeah
those are like classic classic can you
still smoke cigarettes in that room no I
mean the staff does but I think they
just cut it off like but yeah they were
the last they were the last to do it so
you can't but um yeah it's a throwback
man it's just uh you know it's it's I
mean those people are like my family
they're the killer on that club the guy
in the wheelchair at the door whatever
his Dan was a small monster that guy
he's got so many of those things where
you think I'm doing a bit
you know like just for example like
somebody called The Comedy Club one day
and uh they want to know if the comedian
was blue and and Dan said
the headliner is African-American and
the feature Act is white I know that
that sounds like I'm making a bit of but
I'm not but he was serious he was
completely
and he's comedy club for 15 years and
you didn't know the terminology blue
yeah then they had that waitress there
the blonde lady she was older daddy she
had the Patty she had the Bob hairdo and
uh she's counting money she's like my
sister man she was so cool and I'm
drinking you know just the club's over
they're counting money she's smoking and
she's like I saw Seinfeld in 88. he
sucked then and he sucks now
Patty Patty I mean this is this woman is
like my sister man yeah I've known her
forever but she kind of Judges a comic
by how much she rang and that [__] like
like oh God like I'm not so sure she did
she's funny too she's very funny and but
she she listens to jokes but I mean
she's heavily influenced by like yeah
yeah that was uh Bill Hicks and we
didn't we didn't ring very good
I was just talking to a buddy Rana and
about like how well Bill hicks's [__]
holds up oh like it's like better than
ever it's kind of crazy like someone
Ireland I love George Carlin some of
Carl and stuff it's either amazing or
it's just like kind of weird yeah it was
like Hicks it's kind of like oh even the
[__] where he's just bombing that Flying
Saucer tour oh yeah bombing with his
heady material yeah in like Alabama I
know it's kind of amazing I saw him live
one time in a club man where in Houston
where he's from the laptop yeah I was
like no someone you're not drinking with
me oh drink we're doing a couple yes
sorry man no all right Mark I'll do
another one but Celica is famous for his
uh horrific [__] well these are these
are bottle drink thankfully all right
thanks skipper
you gotta put more ice in that Gilligan
what are you doing
what Jesus Christ
how about like just a ton of ice and a
little bit of bourbon yeah
oh it's yours yeah Mark and I made a
whiskey we got a little fuzz on you I
got you yeah
um where are we seeing uh yeah Hicks man
what year was this this was uh probably
91. oh wow and I was doing open mic in
Houston it's they sent me down there to
that's what that special I just sell
potato chips and and peanut butter and
it's my first job oh wow Houston Texas
and I was doing
uh I went to do open mics and uh it was
Ralphie May was doing open mics at the
time wow and I didn't know anything
about comedy we're the only Survivor
from this yeah
I mean now that I think of it there's a
lot of guys Robert schima was there yeah
Patrice O'Neal Greg Geraldo so I'm like
Jordan when I was growing up I didn't
know much stand-up I just didn't I was
real into like movies and Saturday Night
Live and uh yeah who was like your SNL
people that you that you loved uh
Belushi yeah and um I mean Eddie Murphy
Eddie Murphy was the first stand-up that
I really heard and was like oh my God
that's insane you know he changed the
game but I was there and so I didn't
know who was who and uh Ralphie was like
Hey this guy we were at open mic and
Ralph he's like this guy's in town this
weekend he's like from here he's a
legend you got to go see him so me and
my buddy Monty Kilburn just went and
watched him and I sat in the back and
it's still one of the funniest shows
I've ever seen man and it was not
it's funny because Hicks the way all his
albums are it's very political and very
like slanted and you're like silly still
that's he was all silly in that [__]
like all I just man he told this bit
about
ah God I can't like like asking him he
talks about his dad a lot he told us a
bit about you know asking about some
guys who whenever he asked somebody
about how they're doing they're dead I
can't remember what he's like hey how's
your dad he's like oh man like yeah but
it was it was so great and he came out
to music which I'd never seen before
it's like it's really cool like alt rock
song and I was this is this guy is a
badass wow
Patty said he's not good you know yeah
yeah
did he was he uh was it a big venue you
saw him no it's a lap stop man which was
before you guys time but you know 250
seat Club I think he was yeah yeah man
and go and watch Greg's special right
after watching this he really is killer
it is killer that peanut butter bit
about the uh the oil on top oh my God
how has no one done that I've hated that
my whole life I'll tell you how they
have him Tim they didn't sell peanut
butter
I I I paid for that bit
we've all seen the liquid on top yeah
what the [__] yes and haters you didn't
live it though man
I I had to go against those guys man but
wait a minute so I eat peanut butter
every day I'm hooked on peanuts yeah I
love peanut butter what kind do you do I
just do the [__] I do Jiff and yeah
well I didn't want you guys to judge me
with some organic horse [__] I'd do the
the you know the the Jiff is there's
it's a great peanut butter man choosy
mom yeah there you go it's not it's a
superior it's got a little molasses in
there it's my go-to no it's my I mean
it's you do you [__] on chunky chunky is
my favorite I did not [__] on chunk you
said but you said that they're over the
creamies I think that I've always felt
you're creamy creamy all day I don't
want creamy's four to one guys yeah I
mean these are wow 2001 numbers so I I I
would imagine the books I imagine it
still holds up yes that was one of the
first you know you know when you're
young and you have like the jokes that
you repeat remember snaps those books of
insults I'd be like I remember the one
where you say you said a kid in school
you'd be like first or second grade
you'd be like dude your mom's legs are
like peanut butter smooth and easy to
spread that was a big one that's a great
joke I was uh my moms are like they're
crunchy
I think I got most of mine from Like Fat
Albert oh yeah you you're like School in
the summer time no class yeah yeah yeah
man well hey your mom's so fat when she
sits around the house she really sits
around the house your mom's so dumb when
I said uh it's chilly outside she got a
bowl she's so fat she put on high heels
she struck oil yeah
I think is uh your mom's so old she
doesn't have milk in her tits she's got
sour cream no I never heard that good
one damn snaps yeah your mom's so fat
she uses the equator as a belt uh yeah
but I was a kid that's what I thought
like adults did they like stood around
come here
okay table cigars what a disappointment
your mom's so old when they when God
said let there be light she flipped the
switch all right
I know them all I remember that classic
scene in Nutty Professor speaking of
Eddie Murphy it's just they're just
doing that yeah yeah yeah yeah and the
whole Chappelle like should I get him
should I really get him he stole that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
can you imagine being a young can be
like a young Dave Chappelle doing
killing that heart in front of Eddie
Murphy like imagine being that funny in
front of this huge legend by the way
Jada Pinkett sitting right next to him
her man's being insulted she doesn't do
that oh she had a hair that's her what
yeah we play this man
oh
look at the energy
[Laughter]
ah
[Music]
just left him
[Laughter]
she's [__] up when he really
Chappelle's a better high energy comic
than most common yeah better low energy
comic all I'm thinking about is all the
clips he's getting
you think it was like one guy Dave was
channeling when he did this and there's
like five different guys
in here
what's the possible Direction here for
Chipotle look at the dance I think they
just let him go
excuse me
oh no he's gonna get over here
[Music]
kind of smart
got any Murphy's good yeah that's a good
one then oh boy you got more cracking
you know what the crazy thing about that
movie is that Eddie Murphy plays like
seven different characters and they all
have depth I know yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like the mom is like a real human
the dad is they're all real people yeah
Grandma yeah coming to America
characters were pretty good too man the
barber shop the Jewish guy he also
played the uh the singer in that church
thing amazing that was ours was that our
city I think that was I think that was
Murphy I don't think so though what's
going down episode or that's my mama guy
yeah yeah with Jerry curl yeah yeah that
guy Sexual Chocolate
[Music]
no that's uh
I think that's Eddie that's gonna be
Eddie
oh yeah it is
well he's also got a good voice yeah I
mean he's got that hit song that album
Quincy Jones just made him an album I
guess you just couldn't say no to Eddie
Murphy
he's like just make me an album he's
like fine yeah well there was uh put it
in the butt
put a bone in your butt or put a
microphone in your butt or put me in
your butt I put a bumblebee so there was
that one but then my girl likes to party
a town out all the time is like a hit
really my girl likes to party pull up my
girl can we are we allowed to play any
of this Peters
you gotta go quick
my girl likes to party all the time
charted top I don't know it was easily
top five really you know it is that Rick
James
I guess he was robbed of an Oscar for
Dream Girls he should have won for them
yeah he was pissed about that he was he
was amazing in there yeah but you can't
place you can't just expect Awards if
you're a comedian well they gave Rodney
a record too don't forget no oh my God
I think it's up here somewhere
Rodney
he's already funny
[Laughter]
as a kid you're laughing at this but
he's like I hope I die yeah yeah that's
crazy but I found this [__] hilarious
did uh you see you got Hedberg on the
wall yeah he's there he is a death wall
here oh man oh yeah you're next yeah
I uh
I did I got to work with him early on
open for him like three or four times
how was that it was great man he was so
cool dude that and that guy love comics
and he uh he tipped me one time as a
feature like Lynn his wife at the end of
the week was like she was like hey Mitch
wanted to have this you know it's like
100 bucks when you're yeah feature act
man you know I saw him what else you
know it's a big deal with a guy who's
got a debilitating drug problem is
giving out money oh man he was like
that's a good dude I mean he was he was
uh God at this story I feel like this
isn't my story to tell but I'm telling
him yeah the plus it's not my story man
this is Henry Phillips told me this
story oh he's funny he said back in the
towards the end Mitch was like and Mitch
and Lynn were living off the grid and
Mitch was huge and he was making a bunch
of cash and he was every he was sweet
every time I saw him he's just generous
and nice and um was he in a van a
trailer or no I think they just I don't
know that I mean they just stayed in
hotels
in the Chelsea Hotel for a while
there one time I stayed in his room what
I was like still selling peanut butter
in Houston and he was friends with my
buddy Brian Hersey is a comic uh again
him and hers you were tight and uh we
came up to New York and Mitch was on the
road and uh we just came to see what New
York was like and uh
we stayed in his place and I remember
like he had like a calendar there and he
had like Letterman on that like he wrote
Letterman it was so cool to see that's
incredible so yeah we stayed at Mitch's
in the Chelsea Hotel and uh we didn't
know like we didn't know anything about
comedy you know we just we just both
like opened micros or whatever and we
came and we and when you say stay did he
just have a huge room or something it
was like a like a hotel like one guy
slept on the bed I slept on the floor
um but it was you know we just came to
was it like first time in New York I
think as an adult and uh and then we
went to the comic strip and a towel was
there and we had matatelle before
because he worked the laptop down there
and he it was like we just sort of sit
in the bar and it tells like hey why
don't you guys uh go pick yourselves a
spot out you know why just making fun of
us we had no idea so uh so anyways this
so Mitch is living off the grid kind of
and it just has cash he didn't have
credit cards back then he just and he
had a lot of cash Mitch was making huge
money huge money and um so they go to
this hotel
and the guy goes I need a credit card
and Mitch goes I don't have a credit
card and the guy's like well I need a
credit card and Mitch like pulls out a
giant thing of cash he's like no man
like here this should cover cover at
times 10. yeah the guy's like I still
need a credit card Mitch goes this is
how much is mine work he goes hey man no
I mean this this is what the credit card
represents
check us out check this out he goes he
goes so Mitch that would be like if you
hired a Frank Sinatra impersonator and
Frank Sinatra showed up and you were
like no man we hired the impersonator
which is like it's the greatest and that
wasn't an analogy that wasn't even his
act right that's just the way his mind
works
give me a receipt and file it under D
for donuts wow
under the
D that's incredible yeah yeah I am that
is uh that's a bit that's amazing oh
it's a great bit man it's like
everything that I would want yeah and
it's so him too yeah everything Hedberg
would have been so good at Twitter oh
because you would have read everything
in his voice and it would have been like
perfect yeah he Biz Twitter yeah that's
his whole act yeah I'm hungry for rice
is what you want ten thousand or
something or whatever that's a perfect
everyone was always the one where he
goes I like to uh I sit around I think
of stuff that's funny or if it's of a
Pen's too far away I have to convince
myself that what I thought yeah yeah
yeah it's a great job or what's the
other uh you can't please all the people
all the time but and last night all
those people
That's like [__] perfect yeah yeah he
said something one time he's like uh
you know I always like if you want to if
you want to buy something after if you
want to talk to me after the show I
would be shocked
he hit a million of them yeah I'm
against picketing but I don't know how
to show it oh yeah that's like brilliant
I think my favorite was the guy that uh
he was playing his music really loud and
his neighbor started beating them oh
yeah Mitch goes go around
you know and I cannot open the water the
guy in that story is no Nick de Paulo no
way really they were living in L.A that
makes it even more amazing and his
neighbor's dead angry yeah them together
is like a sick oh yeah man I was angry I
would watch every episode of that stuff
you told me a story I don't know was it
you told me the the uh Ron White story
oh yeah another one that's not my story
but yeah but it's like the most insane
story this is like comics on the road
people don't know that we stay in like
comedy condos yeah yeah this is but this
is I mean Ron is a legend Ron is another
guy that is insanely cool he's so nice
he was God I remember one time
he was like I when I was living L.A I
had like a showcase at the Hollywood
improv which that you it was just never
a good crowd it was always industry
there did you realize yeah I was like
they threw me on it wasn't like they
were nice enough to even throw me on the
woman who booked the Rita is like the
coolest oh she's so nice and uh yeah and
they threw me on I went on first the
host kind of ate it and then I was kind
of like well I guess I'm hosting you
know
went up and yeah it just was work I I it
wasn't like a hard bomb but it wasn't
pretty yeah I had a real epidemic with
these bad hosts that's a problem I blame
them too it was well they're putting the
worst comic as hosts because I don't
think people want to host so then you're
as the first guy you you you're on lunch
there's good hosts in New York but yeah
I know what you mean yeah I gotta be
honest I didn't always like following
those guys either man that's a whole
different bag of hammers yeah yeah like
like Artie at the cellar just killing
and I'd be like oh no man right so much
energy different energy yeah yeah all
right sorry wrong one oh Ron White yeah
so Ron yeah yeah just I was I was doing
some showcase and Ron and Ron was big at
the time man I met him doing something
and uh oh we did the road together and
uh he like went and sat like in the show
and laughed at every one of my dumb
jokes you know when you're like I was
like insecure and like I gotta impress
the industry I gotta get this TV show or
whatever I was trying to get so Ron was
just there just like as you know
um but yeah the story is I think this
was in Columbus and it was at a condo uh
and it was like Ron and some guy that
was real green on the road this guy a
real real green act like kind of
Straight Arrow type of guy and Atlanta
was African-American
so that so Ron this kid has like some
orange juice okay and he puts it in the
refrigerator
and Ron uh
Ron goes out and does you know what I
don't I never done drugs man I don't
even know what like but Ron Ron goes out
and he brings back a bunch of acid
and he puts it in the orange juice and
the kid wakes up the next morning and he
drinks like half the pitcher of orange
juice and Ron stubbles out and seen he
goes Buddy you just did about five hits
of acid and this [__] freaks out he's
like no no man I don't do drugs man I
don't do drugs what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen Ron grab some
picture drinks the rest I don't know
buddy but I'm gonna be right there with
and that kid was Ari shaffir
that is uh that is a crazy story that's
what's so great about Ron is because you
think these Blue Collar Comedy Tour Jeff
Fox were they billing well they're all
kind of these clean-cut but Ron's an
animal
always when I was when I was in the
condo with a man it was just he was
either eating chicken wings or drinking
or you know or high or doing something
and I remember this was when he was just
about to break like he had done Blue
Collar yeah they filmed it but it wasn't
out yet but he knew it was gonna pop he
knew some he knew it was on to something
I love it so we're we're in Tulsa at the
Tulsa comedy club and it's like one of
my first weeks on the road and the place
is trashed it's just trashed man and I'm
like Ron doesn't care you know but I'm
like man I have to come back here like
yeah this is gonna come back on me so
I'm cleaning up all this stuff and I see
Ron's check
balled up in the corner he just forgot
his check and it was like it was like
like he forgot it Jesus I still remember
it was for like twenty five hundred
dollars Ron was walking at a club for
2500 and I remember
me yeah he'd given me his uh his number
and I was like hey hey man you left your
checks like yeah buddy you don't have to
send that to me
but uh damn these Comics are so
unorganized you know be included like
Norm couldn't drive nobody knows how to
not being able to drive
and who can't drive well at least you're
in a city with Transportation okay yeah
that makes sense
yeah you know Nate can barely read
everybody's got uh we all got issues I
could barely book a flight you know
we're all over you gave yourself the
nicest one there though well I had to
throw myself in there Joe's got hurt
I can't book a flight Joe has herpes A
friend of ours has AIDS homophobic
so what you said about Ron laughing at
your set it's so interesting because
that [__] goes such a long way when
you're a young comic I remember doing a
festival in Jamestown New York and I was
in like the Copa Cabana room it's the
Lucy Fest and Regan comes in Brian
and I just and I'm like in my head I'm
like [__] Brian Regan I see him in the
corner so I'm just like look away and I
kind of peek back he's laughing I'm like
holy that moment as a young comic you're
like huge holy [__] you'll never forget
that man totally that guy's another
Prince of a guy that he's like oh you're
supposed to have him on here a couple of
times but just travel [__] didn't work
out but fun regions this is how nice
Regan is somebody dropped out his opener
dropped out so his agent calls me and
they're like hey I heard about you we
need an opener tomorrow asap we'll fly
you out can you work clean I was like
yeah he goes can you be clean though and
I was like hey I could be clean he goes
send me a clean tape so I set him a
Tonight Show tape this is years ago and
he writes he calls me back he's like are
you [__] kidding me I said clean
you're talking about gay people you're
talking about I'm like it's clean though
he's my roommate he was gay like he's
like you're talking about this you use
innuendo and I'm like okay the guy kind
of went hard on me oh really I was like
geez yeah yeah in the bed yeah yeah
and I was like Jesus Christ all right
lost that gig tried to send him a clean
tape whatever two days later Regan calls
me and goes hey I just talked to my age
and I heard what he did I watched the
tape it was hilarious [__] that guy
don't listen to him
I hope hope to meet you one day or
whatever and I was like oh my God he
didn't have to do that but he called me
just because he knew his agent was a
[__] now he's a he's a great guy yeah I
can't wait to get him on because he
drinks we'll have it oh he drank Irvine
yeah he's fun he came to the show at
Irvine and he was like one of the first
Comics to drink it so I was like oh yeah
I'll put him back I uh one time it was a
it was especially came out and as an
idiot I was reading the comments you
know and uh somebody's like this is a
Brian Regan bit and I just you know I
just went white with feet I'm like oh no
yeah of course oh no and so I I don't
know him that well I know his brother
really well well he sold peanut butter
for years
you know what he's got a bit about
peanut butter and jelly the goober oh
that's a great thing I stayed away from
that yeah I always give people because
I'm doing 20 minutes on Peanut Butter
like what about goobers I'm like I can't
talk about it
this is a very funny comic Dennis Dennis
is great so I I'm freaking out that I
stole one of Brian Regan's bits and yeah
I get his email and I send an email and
uh
he calls me he just calls me I was at
lunch with some some comics and he calls
me and I'm like oh he goes uh he goes
where are you right now I go uh I go on
the lunch with in St Louis he's like man
I thought you'd be in San Quentin with
the you know how much of a thief you are
he goes dude I don't have any material
anything remotely like that you're fine
like like oh what a guy yeah you get
nervous for some reason Nick Griffin is
always like one of the first guys I need
to because he does so many short
relationships that I'm always but he's
always yeah he's I I think there's so
many great great and yeah and there's
some of them are so effortless but
there's a lot of effort in it so it's
yeah they seem effortless yeah they seem
effortless so you think it's like
something you could just through osmosis
Dennis has got a bit where he says it's
one of my favorite things weird he like
did it in the Green Room in Dallas one
time he goes uh yeah man
I was at this party with my wife she
drugged me to and she goes uh she goes
this guy was there man he's one of those
guys I didn't like him he goes uh yeah
yeah people either they either love me
or they hate me and he goes yeah I bet
it's not 50 50.
those class jokes I mean Nick Nick has
so many of those too Nick has one where
he goes uh my wife and I you know we we
got divorced you know we were supposed
to be together until uh we were together
two years we were supposed to be
together till death I never even got a
cold
that's a great [__] joke he's got a
million of them with Brad Pitt yeah
that's what I was thinking he's like no
no
go watch go watch any Nick Griffin like
Letterman said right now he's got a new
special coming out so we gotta get along
all bangers these Letterman sets are a
lesson it's a master class how to do a
late night set man totally I wonder if
young Comics even think about that [__]
anymore do you think they even know and
they probably shouldn't yeah but you
know what those are Clips right I mean
those are you're getting Clips but uh
five minutes of Clips yeah but Nick
Griffin Letterman sets are like to me a
master class easily so good so relatable
clean but you don't notice it's clean
you're clean yeah so but there's a bite
and there's like yes yeah I hope like
same with like a guy like Ryan Hamilton
he's clean but there's like an edge too
oh yeah oh yeah I was watching him last
night there's an edge to what he's
saying he's great yeah yeah he's he's I
was listening to your guys podcast
Hamilton can dance oh my God Twinkle
Toes he's good cuts a rug out there I've
seen in my wedding see they the the
floor opens up for us everybody back oh
[__] he's going he whips the jacket off
he's doing all this [__] really oh my
God I saw Stone and stone and his wife
at uh list wedding he was he was doing
pretty good Hamilton was dancing at that
wedding oh yeah yeah that's where I saw
it it's funny you talk about that like
blue-collar Comedy Tour thing because
Norman sends me a thing this weekend I'm
on you know I'm on the road Norman sends
me a thing and it was of me list and
Mark we tried to sell a special years
ago
oh my God was that that was no we didn't
we got an offer from quip okay that was
the only place we got an office yeah
can you think how much how big that
special will be right now well I mean it
just we I think there was some
inspiration from the blue collar tour
where like these are a bunch of dudes I
think the difference is they were so
different and Mark Joe and I were just
joking I saw our theme was like it was
just called jokes jokes jokes unless I
was just doing 20 minutes each like bang
bang we shot a trailer and everything I
forgot we did this oh it sends it to me
we'll play it we'll play the trailer on
a future episode for you guys it's
pretty it's pretty good at patreon yeah
it's a good one uh but it's crazy to
look at it like like holy [__] we were
trying to sell it together yeah and we
just like and nobody would touch us I
remember at the time I you know I knew
Sandler a little bit and I asked him if
he would help oh and he did and they
said and they still they said no to
Sandler well we didn't know I mean they
said no to us not to Sandler he was
being he's the nicest dude in the world
really yeah he really is and he was
trying to help us but you know uh I
think it was just
for them at the time made no sense yeah
it's three Whitey you know we weren't we
had no juice it wasn't a very appealing
for the industry but it was like it was
a funny thing to look back I was like
man it's like fun even when you don't
sell [__] it is kind of fun to do [__]
together yeah I got all these like
sketches that me and Henry Phillips and
uh oh put them on Chad Daniels wow Nikki
Glazer was Nikki was like a kid like wow
she was like in college still drinking
uh yeah yeah she was back then yeah I
mean they were someone man some of the
Henry's a really good actor all those
guys great actor great comic funny Jamie
listo was in it wow wow yeah it's pretty
good St Louis is a crazy alumni is lisso
from St Louis no I just it was uh but
it's like you Nikki Tommy John again
yeah but I I had just like uh Nick
vaderoff from St Louis as well Nick
Vatterott
no Peach Wisconsin yeah uh
that's like almost death time baby
liquid Death Mountain Water flavored
sparkling water I love that uh lime this
I think it's severed lime iced tea may
look like a tall boy can but it's a
non-alcoholic choice you can enjoy
anywhere with flavors like rest in Peach
get it you can make any boring event a
little more exciting yeah I've had this
a bunch I as I said lime Seltzer I get
in my Green Room a lot I love it uh you
you've had this [__] right Mark love it
big fan I got them all at home I like
all the flavors I mix them with booze
Mountain Water just don't go with a
Julian Sands bad joke all right rest in
peace drinking liquid death is a great
is great for the environment they donate
a portion of the profits from every
canned soul to help and plastic
pollution why would you drink anything
else pick up a case and start violently
murdering your thirst today
that's right genocide on your [__]
bod let's do it you can find liquid
death healthy beverages on Amazon or
real a retailer near you plus we might
be drunk listeners get 20 off their
first liquid death apparel purchase
available exclusively at liquiddeath.com
drunk exclusions May apply that's
liquiddeath.com drunk how about this for
their next drink genocider
take it liquid death you're welcome
all right hey we might be drunk is
brought to you by doer wearing them
right now do or die look at that big fan
they feel great they smell great they
fit like a goddamn glove the bed the
waist is a little perfectly stretchy you
look like a summertime Mass shooter it's
beautiful yeah
I feel like a lesbian who's cleaning out
a cage at the zoo oh boy when door sent
us over there top of the line shorts I
didn't expect them to be this good I can
move in these things that's big Linings
everything huge huge a lot of Earth very
constricting but these are really you
can breathe but they're not too good it
feels like it's suffocating in some of
those yeah it pushes it up I hate that
exactly choke my dick choke the chicken
it makes the world's most couple pants
breathable lightweight durable they
never go out of style that's true these
are Timeless I gotta be honest I just
got these today I've never taken them
off I'm gonna have sex with my wife in
them I love them cool pockets they call
this a uh what is this called some kind
of weird cargo
yeah that zipper that's it I love them
too I'm gonna have sex with Mark's wife
and him too there we go do her send me
the video I prefer a black guy if you're
a doer these tough cool shorts and pants
will keep up with you you're not boring
don't let your pants be and it's not
only pants but they got an entire
menswear line of jeans joggers shorts
tees jackets and they make you look
sharp while keeping up with your busy
lifestyle made from materials like wood
chips plants and recycled bottles whoa
Dewer has finally made sustainable
clothing that's long lasting and stylish
trust me you need to add doer to your
summer wardrobe check out doers Flagship
stores in La and Denver or go online at
shopdoer.com our listeners get 15 off
site wide using our code drunk for 15
off your order go now to
shopdoer.com s-h-o-p-d-u-e-r.com
[Music]
promo code drunk shopdoer.com promo code
drunk get on it Pete would be such a
good murderer if they made like Fargo
season five yeah oh geez oh honey oh why
are you making me kill you
[Laughter]
Sanford and Son is so [__] so funny
you better keep sucking on that sucker
sucker that's my favorite part from that
yeah I love that show well you know what
that's what I love about comedy is these
guys are all just degenerate balls to
the wall crazy [__] and then
the industry Scoops them up and then
they're supposed to be like cleaned up
and nice and presentable but they're
still that guy yeah that's why I love
red fox on Esther the you know the lady
who plays honestly I can't remember her
name she is she's filthy man that if you
ever oh really yeah filthy she's the one
that plays on Esther and she's really
hot as a younger woman pull her up yeah
she was Red's friend in high school or
something or coming up in St Louis and
they wanted an actress and and she's a
comic and she was in red said well then
you're not having a sitcom because she's
gonna play on Esther I can tee off on
her because she's a comic he didn't feel
right yeah yeah she was hot look at this
is really hot man wow oh yeah that was a
great one to page Lawanda go watch those
old Dean Martin roasts she's like she's
you
there's a story about red fox where
there's these two big big fat guys that
were twins out of St Louis called uh
Zach and Mack and they were and this was
when when Reds like you know there's
three channels on TV and Sanford and
Son's the biggest thing going yeah he's
at Dangerfield's one night and uh he's
just murdered you know he's red foxes oh
yeah and uh so he goes down the Green
Room in Dangerfield and Zack and Mac
went on stage and he had no idea who
they were and uh they're from St Louis
and uh and and reds he's listening he's
like who these guys up there killing
after me who's following me trying to
kill after me and he goes up there and
he sees him and he laughs and then he
brings them down the green room and he
talks to him and he finds out there from
St Louis he's like I don't want to put
you on my show wow two weeks later they
play bodyguards in on Sanford and Son
like wow there's no way you would get
that done these days honestly no I love
that I love helping out the comics even
are there anymore there's nothing and
also like with the writers strike that I
mean who the [__] I mean hopefully by
the time this is out that's over but I
doubt it right yeah they're saying 100
days at least
probably it's hard enough to it takes a
long enough time to sell a show to make
a show I know and then and then you put
all this [__] involved this kind of and
it sucks because like I didn't I love
doing this show like Mark and I have a
ton of fun but like I didn't think this
was gonna be our thing I didn't think
like right like I think we got into
comedy thinking like I didn't want to
get I didn't get into comedy to be like
[__] Don Imus no I wanted I wanted to
make like a sitcom you know I want to
make like a show and I still do and
maybe you know someday at some point but
it's just God oh yeah the the the Hoops
you have to jump over brutal with these
with these industries well that's why
pods are so popular because you can just
do it you don't need to wait for people
and get you know the uh the yes and the
no and the red tape and the legal and
he's doing different like Steps yeah and
then they still in the end say no or
like I've had friends that have I've
seen friends comics and then my writer
friends have like gotten it all the way
to the end yep and then by the time you
get at the end it doesn't look anything
like what you yeah it started with
because they messed with it the industry
stinks because how many things have
started online then they go oh that's
doing well buy it and you're like well
if I had pitched it to you would have
said no but now that you see it kicking
they're kicking ass now you want it they
have no money they need a complete proof
of concept they can't you guys should
have something
at some point man you know but right now
this is we're having fun you know oh
yeah we got no one telling us what to do
make a show make sound accused My
Bodyguard and uh
I'll go get it I don't know how this
works
he's supposed to fill the glass with ice
this was a nice little bottle cocktail I
like yeah these negronis are all right I
never drink man really yeah I'd barely
ever Jeezy
sorry well let me ask you because I
drink his lace with a five hits of acid
yeah yeah yeah that's the ice you need
every clean comic has a dark side really
yeah you know uh Seinfeld loves kids but
Hamilton once raped a baby yeah the
Whisk goes on and on Hamilton you got
the other guy Regan's a booze hound what
is your what is your hook I like
gambling
now we're getting somewhere yeah I like
the gamble okay I like playing cards
what do you got on Biden's death all
right what what do you think uh is it
poke or Blackjack what do you think
what's that man it's uh it's a terrible
it's a really dark game it's that uh
ultimate Texas Hold'em oh suck in yeah I
grew up playing that it's like they're
gonna say like Uno yeah I bet it all
dude Connect Four I lost my house
oh it's like it's like Blackjack you
play the dealer you play Texas Hold him
against the dealer yeah I was playing
this weekend my friend my roommate in
college would pay rent with that [__]
online really that's so [__] risk I
knew a kid like that too but it's so
risky it is yeah it's not a good game
man no yeah you're not gonna win I mean
he was always like come on let me
borrowed 20 bucks I just like being
there and playing like if it's a five
dollar table
it's great because because a five dollar
table on that game that means you're
betting the way I bet you're probably
betting anywhere from 20 to 40 on the
hand right with that's a five dollar
minimum so I was I was at this and I I
could play that all day long you know I
it's just I just like playing but if it
goes to 10 man now it's like you know
it's an 80 to 150 hand or something it's
like it's too much it's too much it's
just too much so I'll do that but only
when I think I got more money than I
really have and so you got the bug but
you're not a psycho no no no I'm not I'm
not I'm not out of control because guys
will lose their their families over this
no I don't have a family but yeah
damn all right I'm so glad I don't have
the gambling bug I've lost every hand
I've ever played I I lose every slot
I've never won the end of the night
sometime I'm just like just fine and I'm
like [__] you I'll just like keep
putting more yeah okay oh my God if I'm
hammered you you don't bet the Knicks do
you I don't bet on Sports because I
actually like watching me neither I
don't bet baseball yeah you're such a
big Cardinals fan right huge but I don't
like that I got the shirt on right here
yeah it's like a mix of my buddy's band
who's a comic it's he's got this band
called Ludo and he's a he's got a song
about pterodactyls oh cool he did a
thing at Bush Stadium yeah they had like
they had a couple big hits at one time
were you bummed are you were your
football fan were you bummed when the
Rams left I was bummed when the
Cardinals left when I was a kid this the
football Cardinals left to go to Arizona
that really hit me and then I mean I and
then I went to Houston and the Oilers
left and went to Tennessee we're leaving
right after the show yeah
everything's falling apart and then uh
and then and then the Rams left so I
hate the NFL I just wow three teams that
I've lost tonight that's tough I wasn't
a giant Rams fan I followed it but
baseball baseball and college wrestling
I'm like in as much as you can be in you
were a legit wrestler yeah yeah I was
yeah I was good I wasn't like that next
level but I was I was good I mean that's
a tough sport the cut and weight you
know the hand it's hand to hand you
gotta you gotta go out of the guy if
you're terrified put your arms out like
that man you gotta have men you gotta
have men yeah yeah and then the singlet
alone is is intimidating
yeah a little onesie that's what throws
it's not a onesie that's not the name of
it man well you could what do you call
it a single singlet okay onesie onesie
onesies sounds like you're taking a shot
no no but it is it is one piece of
clothing it's a legit move is that a
what is that a butt plug that's what's
going on there the checking the oil oh
man and they do that I've been there
it's a rare thing this looks like my
honeymoon
[Laughter]
milk in the process did you Google that
yeah okay
your name and wrestling and I got this
can you can you imagine if you went to
like a real wrestling match
there's a really like there's a picture
that shows of me and a singlet that's
like oh look it up yeah
sneaks up on me every now and then
wrestling match with my brother where I
did that move because you're desperate
the other finger in the ass oh yeah
literally you know that's what makes you
come years later it's crazy it's a good
move uh w-a-r-r-e-n
yeah there's two things on the internet
there's that two very hard words to
spell math yeah right
wrestling is w-r-e okay yeah that's it
oh [__]
this is getting porn look at this it's
exactly what you're not supposed to do
in a wrestling picture is smile either
it's the stupidest thing wrestling
pictures and mug shots you don't smile
yeah you don't smile
yeah in the middle there see if you in
the middle it's that's the only match of
mine on uh here yeah oh here we go
that's me getting worked by the two-time
national champ man whoa oh is this it
wait which one are you I'm the guy
getting whooped in the maroon okay he
only lost
three times this whole college career
damn wow he is good he's ferocious yeah
I now if you get later on like he he
kills me he kills me but I did get on
top of him okay there you go
uh ah in the second period I get on top
of him I start cranking on his leg and
he had a bad leg you know ah smart this
is true man my coach before this match
was like he's like I don't care who this
guy is worn you take it to him you don't
show him any respect you go after him so
I and here I am I'm working him pretty
hard here on top all right there you go
yeah yeah so uh so at one point I don't
know somewhere here they stopped the
match okay they stopped the match
because his knees hurt yeah yeah right
there his knees hurt he goes over to his
corner see his legs hurt yeah yep now at
this point I go over to my corner I'm
thinking yeah rope the coach he's going
to be proud of me goes Warren
I'm not sure I would have pissed this
guy off
and he was right he was right man the
guy ripped my head off afterwards
only match on the internet of mine in
college wow because you [__] his leg
up he was yeah he was he was good that's
when you got to put him in the figure
four leg lock yeah that's what I had him
in that's oh there it is
way more man he's angry but see there's
no [__] around in this sport you know
there's no team to rely on it's just you
and this other guy that's what I love
about it yeah he made me look silly a
couple times here I watch a lot of fist
fight videos like bar fights and parking
lot fights I feel like they're promoting
that [__] on Twitter more than ever oh
Twitter fight Haven Great Falls I know
it's like just I don't even follow it
but it comes up all the time well I
bring it up because a lot of the guys
especially the the honkies they they
fight and they go in you could tell they
took wrestling in college or high school
because they go for the legs they flip
the guy over and then they just get on
top or they do a choke hold and I wish I
knew it I wish I took wrestling you'd
see I don't think you'd take wrestling
sorry uh performed yeah that's it yeah
like shop class
yeah you wrestle man I wish I wrestled
yeah and Kyle I wrestled my sexuality
but that was about it
so yeah aren't you glad you have it no
the basketball yeah no bar fight you can
you know more than the other guy already
yeah I mean I don't really need to be
getting any bar fights at my age but but
you did you tackled a guy in the village
once yeah there we go yeah yeah yeah
that that happened that I got I got
punched in the face in the in the East
Village and I shot a single leg on him
and uh and took him down that's what I'm
talking about yeah but he was like
that he the punch wasn't bad but like
after that he had it was like he was on
something yeah you know I was new in New
York at the time what a [__] welcome
I know I know it's that welcome and I
called like I think I called my brother
who had lived in Jersey for long he's
like ah it's just the East Coast man I'm
like what I called another one of my
friends
I called vecchione to tell him he's a
wrestler yeah who's a wrestler in a
comic and you know I just met Mike when
I moved here but I immediately loved the
guy he's a wrestler he's a great comic
yeah so I called Mike to tell him and
then I called another one of my friends
he's like dude this is because somebody
was taping it was was part of the story
somebody was happy he's like dude that
thing that's going to wind up on the
it's gonna wind up on on YouTube man
this is gonna be a break for you this is
going to be your biggest thing
I had a Comedy Central special
it wasn't that good man
that is what you need you need like he's
a comedian we got to look at his [__]
right Jim Jefferies got punched on stage
he said that broke him uh Bill Burr had
the Heckle thing in Philly that kind of
broke him so you need to find a guy on
Fentanyl and kick his ass yeah let's get
the cameras rolling it might be a little
scarier though right he might bite you
or something yeah maybe so wait why the
guy a guy just randomly hit you just
hobo just walking down the East Village
and I go uh it was like you live right
behind me back in the Lower East Side
that's right I lived on Ludlow yeah so I
I was walking down and I I just walked
by the school he goes what are you
looking at man and uh like I turned
around he shouted at me I turned around
which like Judah told me like don't
don't turn around ever yeah Judah was
like don't don't ever turn around Well
everybody's yelling hey world champion
huh he's like let's keep going keep
going so I turned around and you know I
was like that's a crazy guy and then he
like literally sprinted towards me he's
like I said what are you looking at and
I said something stupid you know and
then he and then I like I deserve to be
hit like I had my face out almost like
like right here is where you want to let
me draw an X yeah I was like hey man he
just went bam whoa and for a minute I
was like
I don't know because I was new in New
York you feel like a victim of some sort
so I was like I was like ah what should
I do and I was like wait wait a minute
man I practiced this every day for 20
days I know what to do here yeah and
would you do you single leg to the
single leg to the right side took him
down yeah yeah it went right down and
then I stopped short of like
I was kind of I think I had my hand on
on my thumb on his neck or something and
then wow and then I uh and then I was
like wait a minute this is this guy's
like he's this isn't he's a heroin
addict you know right yeah he can't
fight you called your coach and he's
like I wouldn't have done that oh my
coach that's the thing if that uh video
would have showed up on the internet and
be like Warren you still don't know how
your footwork is terrible
heart
damn that's pretty wild oh you can you
send can you play the video that I sent
you Matt
you sent it to Mr salacus yeah someone
sent me this one Mark's gonna love this
[__] uh-oh we got a fist fight
is that what it is you have it he's
gonna text it to you we can always play
it later should we do news or something
oh yeah
all right so we got a news story here
for you a prisoner who died
uh and was brought back to life argued
that his life sentence was technically
finished this is great this is this
guy's a genius this lawyer is brilliant
what a great uh way to get out of a life
sentence you serve one now you're reborn
this is gold yeah I feel like you know
because they they outlaw they said sorry
man like he lost oh he did yeah he lost
yeah of course which I think they had to
because you know like prisoners if this
worked every prison would be like Doc uh
yeah doc Em Dead He's like you have a
cold
I'm dead and if you ever want to see
your family again I'm dead I have I know
people on the outside yeah I know it's a
cold I'm dead doc write it down I'm dead
we're also here to do not resuscitate
which it's like oh really yeah which by
the way I feel like if you've murdered
someone you should have a do not
resuscitary there should not be a line
in the ER and you're like why are we
waiting so long like we're trying to
save a murderer yeah you know that's
true it is hilarious that they're trying
to it's a technicality yeah like he's
technically dead
but it's like yeah word play I don't
know if that's yeah yeah
the story in the news about this guy who
showed up to uh the hospital and he had
tattoos that do not resuscitate and
there was an argument over the doctor
saying is this a contract can we oh can
we abide by this or do we have to try
and revive him interesting they ended up
Reviving him yeah they've been a house
episode I don't know correct
I love that show that was a great show
love it yeah
no but do news first we'll save this one
uh
they got it they revived this guy with
uh epinephrine it said yeah which is
that's the truck driver speed you know
like those little Mini Thins you see
when oh is that right gas station that's
that's epinephrine oh really well it
tells you like that stuff should not be
yeah for sale a 7-Eleven I've uh I've
had a shot of allergic reaction I have
an epinephrine shot in my leg it saved
my [__] life what happened you just I
had an allergic reaction my eyes were
bugging out and uh wait what are you
allergic to I don't know I don't want to
say because someone could poison me oh
[Laughter]
and it only happened to me one time
no I uh and I remember I was walking to
the hospital with my mom and a bird [__]
on my face and I was just like this
ain't my day yeah but if you say that's
good luck right so yeah I uh
I I walk in they jam into my leg and I
uh you know you're like you know but
then I passed out for like five hours
whoa whoa it's crazy yeah what you were
out I was out yeah how old were you I
was like
12. damn you're opening for Ron White
stuck some of your drink that's a
similar thing where I I had an allergic
reaction I went into one of those WebMD
places whatever it's called you walk in
the clinic the city MD yeah City MD and
there they looked at my face they're
like we're calling 9-1-1 I was like
you're 9-1-1
yeah what are you allergic to I won't
say come on what is it no I think I
think that's reasonable yeah all right
I'm allergic to Gin
breakout in hives got to go to the ER
and get a shot of something yeah damn
this is worse than this will kill me
that's what I don't want to say okay oh
yeah it'll literally murder me and I'll
let the fans in there yeah I got you or
or your lady
this could be her way out all right what
do you got it let's see what's next uh
an Austrian train plays a Hitler speech
on its loudspeaker
[Laughter]
you know they weren't real Nazis because
this was an efficiently they would have
won it efficiently if it was a Nazi
Trend yeah that's true that's true this
is brutal man this story like the only
thing I could think was like
at least like
America is not the only place with like
[__] skinhead yeah dirt bags you know
like they got them over there too that's
the mecca too
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we didn't start
this like right that's what Hitler's
from by the way Austria yeah that's
right but that's uh apparently the air
conditioning went down too on this train
I was like two things
I did check the showers didn't work so
that was it
these poor kid they're just on their way
to Camp you know uh it's it's also funny
I wonder if the guy was just like uh he
just happened to be a Neo-Nazi who
[__] up it's kind of like when you
leave the porn in the VCR you're like oh
[__] that wasn't supposed to play now
that's for later
CR porn jokes Mark G sorry I gotta get
more update that's from that's like a
true lifetale right there right there
what happened to him right there yeah
thank you that's my era
um they shouldn't play this on a train
this this Hitler speed they should play
it in art schools just so you know
they're like hey if you don't get your
[__] together you're gonna end up like
this guy you gotta paint better
I'm gonna use one of the guys the news
said we clearly distance ourselves from
the content which I'm gonna start doing
if my wife catches my DMs I'm like I
distance myself
nothing all right
uh Hitler Hitler speech on a train
that's like playing Jim Crow at an
auction
all right
that's what messed me up I was thinking
oh Jim Crow I guess he didn't give
speeches David Duke
all right all right I'll take it maybe
Jim maybe David Duke got on a on a
cruise
slave shift
he's killed at my apartment
Mark's bargaining with sound like he was
like come on give me a [__] give me
something here oh here we go uh a
Michigan woman uh charged with
caring for wildlife without a permit the
animals were killed by the state
officials so the state officials came in
took her animals away that she wasn't
properly caring for and killed them
that's a weird series of events yeah
it's a little mix mixed message and she
said they said they took it away from
her because they don't want like if you
take in a wild animal chances are when
you put it back out in the wild it's
gonna die yes but the stuff that she was
taking it was like a one-legged grow
yeah it was a wreck a blind rack with
Down Syndrome with Down Syndrome they're
gonna die like like
if you put them back they're gonna die
man I'm with you I was on her side
totally and then did you read her tweet
was it her Facebook post or whatever it
sounds a little bit a little much man
she said
so this Old Farm gal
helps that she called them Woodland
creatures which immediately Ah that's
adorable
I will be arrested please pray I will
light be a light for those I come in
contact with let my hands continue nice
but I was like ah she's a handful she
was charged with uh keeping endangered
creatures in captivity thank God uh Hugh
Hefner is not still alive yeah
yeah also uh you think those girls
didn't want to be there
well some of them didn't some I think
some of them like talked themselves yeah
no I think you're right I think yeah I
don't know if they really I think at a
certain point though like I think
there's and wasn't he on all kinds of
pills like uppers or something oh yeah
yeah was it like uh yeah like 1970s I
mean he was something at that age it's
energy it's not a downer yeah
that's true but he was like a speed
freak kind of guy oh yeah yeah probably
and you know the Viagra and also he had
these strict like it's movie night and
like I just want to go hang out it's
movie night you're all gonna sit around
me and you know watch the movie and pet
me
let me just say this about the uh
Wildlife
I gotta get my jokes in that I worked on
um it's just a weird Series where of
events where they hey you're mistreating
these animals and then we kill them you
know what if CPS did that hey you're not
fit to be a father
all right we got it in
thank God they weren't around I like
where you're heading with that one
though man that's something there yeah
yeah there's there's there there's
definitely a yeah the where were these
uh animal rights activists during Noah's
Ark ah
go back to the CPS thing oh yeah all
right we got any other news
okay so masturbation with a sex toy
kills a man wait which toy I just want
to know for myself here for my future
this is what you're allergic to
uh he gets electrocuted with ping pong
balls up his butt while jerking off in
the Czech Republic yeah I actually saw
that his parents found the body which
like you should not have this Advanced a
sexual fetish and live at home yeah oh
yeah you gotta pick one who did it yeah
how did they not know what was going on
right you were electrocuting your balls
you got to at least afford a studio
who knew and when the also the other
thing like it's the Czech Republic
that's an Eastern European country
they're pretty Frugal over there so
like they're using those ping pong balls
again for something
somebody's gonna be using that guy don't
throw away ping pong balls this is
perfectly good they smell weird Grandpa
he's fine it's fine
this guy's up shit's creek with a ping
pong paddle all right uh
oh [__] hold on well why is it electric
by the way why is it an electric ping
pong because he's I think he was like
electrocuting his balls or something oh
the ball wasn't electrical yeah have you
ever tried to get off with just regular
ping pong
on this Tombstone they wrote Game set
match
there's some people who think regular
masturbation is a sin can you imagine oh
yeah really like wow this guy's really a
piece of [__] yeah the guy that invented
uh Corn Flakes did it because Kellogg he
that was right he was against
masturbation and he thought that what
caused masturbation was Bland was was
spicy food so we made corn flakes as
Bland as he could and he invented graham
crackers they used to be really really
Bland uh no Graham invented graham
crackers and this guy was a disciple it
says so but he did it because if you eat
a bland diet you won't masturbate could
you imagine what he thought these people
were like eating like this guy but then
his brother
his brother like snuck sugar into the
cornflakes she's like oh really there's
an idiot and that's why Kellogg's became
like this yeah how about that yeah uh
subsequent examination revealed that the
electric device malfunctioned when
plugged in and the autopsy revealed
Burns in the skin above the man's penis
can you sue that manufacturer yeah they
probably it's a pretty embarrassing
lawsuit to get sued man yeah like who's
gonna Sue it yeah the parents show up
all right we want Justice all right tell
us exactly what happened never mind why
is it Electro I don't get what is an
electric ping pong ball no it's it's the
device almost like the metal balls no
it's ping pong it's ping pong man I
don't get where how it can be Electric
yeah I'm confused but all right either
way if he was honest please don't look
for photos
nothing
stand by it man they're gonna be these
poor parents they're gonna be triggered
every time they see a ping-pong table
you know
what are there any other stores yeah
sure oh do you have any more more no no
you don't want to hear it
GPS
so a Colorado driver tries to switch
this is gold oh God this is great uh
Colorado driver tries to switch seats
with a dog in a failed attempt to avoid
a du IRS this guy's a real booze hound
you know Little Hair of the Dog uh this
guy was Shih Tzu faced okay this only
works if the cop is also shit-faced
right in which case she's like whoa the
dog is driving I feel like we know guys
that would do this yeah like like it's
because the Ingenuity of a drunk is
especially yeah this guy is a genius
they should have let him go
and you can only double down too you
know they're like hey man he's like what
was the dog swerving because he said he
wasn't drinking man if he was drinking
just on me
that'd be great if they did punish the
dog just he's fine the dog has to do
community service for like three months
[Music]
I wonder what he did
you should just like
I love this guy he gets caught like
[__] his wife's friend he just throws
the dog I know he's like it was him
right bad boy you dirty dog
oh yeah
yeah the cops like ah got another caller
all right
isn't that what they call it a collar
okay okay so we have a story here Italy
calls crisis meeting over surging pasta
prices
um yeah
well you know this is like what this is
funny because it's like exactly what an
ignorant person would think they're
doing in Italy so like I bet they're
[__] arguing about pasta or some [__]
yeah and that is we're like dealing with
like mass shootings and immigration over
here they're just like we got a linguine
crisis right yeah you wonder what wasn't
a crisis before this yeah man there's uh
the mafia is coming back the there's
violence in the streets and uh the
infrastructures crumbling there's an
eight percent raise in pasta price we're
gonna have a meeting
this is this is tragic
yeah they're really pinching pennies
oh
it's reached a boiling point over there
you know with this pasta and uh you know
I blame these uh olive oil tycoons all
right pennies
[Laughter]
last one
what is it oh do you have one more joke
you want me to read the thing no no last
one okay uh man rescued from the woods
after sex game goes awry German police
say 51 year old man who was left tied up
in the woods when a sex game uh went
awry I said that I had a lucky Escape
after a cyclist and a hunter heard his
screams for help wow what's going on
with me me and my wife we have sex
sideways it takes 11 seconds and then we
both watch jury duty you know like who
are these guys going to the woods
getting tied up doing all kinds of
cookie [__] yeah what's wrong with the
bed yes bags are [__] great oral is
good sex is good you don't need a
ping-pong ball or a tied up tree no
judgment but if it kills you some
judgment yes yes agreed did you see that
like the woman that did this to him
she got a phone call supposedly and
that's when she took off and left him
there oh yeah which I want to know what
that phone call
listen uh your kid's in trouble at
school uh they were jumping rope and he
uh he tied somebody up and it's uh it's
a real bad
it is she got found by uh oh he got
found by a cyclist which is so and a
hunter it's so weird like can you
imagine there's like the different ends
of the health Spectrum it's like one
dude one dude's working on his cardio
another dude's tied up in the woods
they're both both of their heart rate is
going for a different reason yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah thank God Dick Cheney
wasn't out there he would have shot that
him in the face yeah so that's an old
reference
told officers that he had a box cutter
with him for such situations but he
couldn't find it man those box cutters
let me tell you something in the grocery
business those things are gold gold yeah
like uh Freddy was the one that told me
like he was like because he was in the
grocery business before but that's how
you bribe the grocery store hey
a couple of box cutters really yeah yeah
oh wow yeah we didn't have it but
Freddie said they had like Clorox so you
know that was his company it was Clorox
or Colgate or something yeah some box
cutters man interesting I knew a guy was
an undercover cop and he got out of a
serious jam with some box cutters like a
fight yeah oh damn yeah those will cut
you up yeah
yeah this is uh that's just for boxes
uh-huh he's lucky this guy these are
kind of like uh where you can the knives
because it just you just press the
tracks yeah yeah it's like a switchblade
yeah yeah
exacto knife is also pretty deadly and
when I was growing up those were called
uh Buck 50s
they would use them for slashing faces
on the subway and you need 150 stitches
one that's in the tool is called a buck
50.
you have a buck 50 on you it meant box
cutter God yeah don't let the outfit
fool you
he's not in from Tahiti working on it
150 stitches
cheese oh yeah who's the guy that the
comic that got that happen too Doug
Smith Doug Smith man amazing bet he has
on great bit yeah it's all true though
right like all true yeah yeah he's a
hero it's on YouTube it's an Irish fear
storytelling show it's great Killer
story
true story
do you have any uh oh sorry Mark no I'm
just gonna say this guy's lucky that
these guys found him that could have
been a lot worse he could have been
found by other sexual weirdos you know
Deliverance 2.0 yes exactly they're like
well look at here we got ourselves a
mouse
served up on a silver platter
my oh my Cletus uh yeah or he knows him
oh yeah not Charlie
this guy's into some weird stuff oh this
dude loves [__] Mouse
you can really bribe him he's like tick
help me help me you're like yeah you
know I've been looking at this big
screen TV on Best Buy whatever you want
man he's like nine nine nine guys
he's in Germany ah nine is no in German
oh he's in German oh I didn't know it
was in Germany I see sorry sorry not pay
attention to Dateline for some of these
things all right sorry any any wrecks or
peeves or anything I actually have some
peeves hit me hold on let me pull these
up I don't know if you got any peeves
there Greg sure what do you got
uh
I've been falling when you when you walk
into a business
and uh and nobody's working there like
nobody's the front it drives me insane
there's hotels are one so you know you
come into a hotel like 11 30 at night
and there's like a sign that says you
know I'll be back in 10 minutes or
because they went to the back like
you're the Holiday Inn you're this giant
company and you you have you can only
have one guy working for yeah for 400
rooms you can only have one guy working
he's gonna have to go to the bathroom
you guys really can't afford two guys I
know you know that that is brutal
Walgreens is another one which it
doesn't hold up as much in the city but
in like Suburban Walgreens you walk in
at 11 30 at night they're open uh
there's one guy working the rest and
yeah and there's he's not there right
you walk in It's upsetting you just feel
like something
did something horrible just happen like
Amazon came along yeah yeah but I mean
you feel like you're giving to a mom and
pop going to Walgreens
yes you want you guys right now you have
one more employee than a vending machine
and you're you're Walgreens man you
can't afford two guys with the AI and
stuff I mean it started with the
self-checkout yeah it's coming for us
yeah you guys scared me so much I
listened to your last episode and you're
talking about
robots writing jokes and stuff like that
oh yeah it's coming baby good it's not
good they're not great yet I Googled I
checked to see if I could write a better
joke and then they're better than mine
tonight
they're not great yet so but give them
five years I'll figure it out yeah no
soul though no souls no soul they could
figure that out yeah so come on Souls of
Pixar movie I did see that there was a
self-checkout that asks for a tip
oh
you gotta be kidding you gotta be
kidding me man so you're just tipping
the company yeah
I love it like like no one's working
here but let me just give uh Howard
Schultz to Starbucks some more money
right my thing is like if you if you're
gonna steal from that place how do you
get in trouble for doing that you don't
tears that's gonna be the new viral
videos there's robots killing unarmed
people oh yeah yeah yeah and they're
gonna be like look we need robots to
patrol the neighborhood they keep us
safe yeah that will that's gonna happen
you're right
good point yeah all right I gotta pee
for you what do you got how about this
guy I hate this guy the guy who gets mad
that you're mad
so I had the guy go uh this guy was
[__] me over I'm not gonna get into
details but he screwing me over and then
I finally see the guy and I go hey
what's going on he goes don't be mad
like you can't tell me not to be mad I'm
mad you [__] me over and now you're
telling me not to be mad you don't get
to do that yeah hate the Dopey mad guy I
think we need details on this thing man
yeah maybe we need details I mean he
took some money from me I've been
houding him about it he's like don't
worry I'll get it to you and I bumped
into him I didn't think I would bump
into him he's like hey
the money's coming don't be mad and I'm
like I'm bad every once in a while you
just want to be like
hit me with it yes be mad I'm allowing
it yeah man you can't do that with the
police don't be upset I did something
illegal you're going to jail
a Sex Dungeon to slow down I know you're
going to be come on yeah you're also the
cheapest guy I know in the world what
circumstance did you lend somebody money
I lend money you guys don't know about
me
it's a comic yeah do I know him oh yeah
everybody knows him it's Jerry Seinfeld
no
um that'd be great if Jerry was just
borrowing money from people he's like
dude just spot me like you know just buy
me like 10 grand well there's some big
Headliners they have no cash it's all
it's all tied up and they got you know
Swiss banks and real estate and cars and
all this open for Jeffrey Epstein yeah
and it was no cash good game good game I
had to tip all the girls
but uh yeah that's yeah that is don't be
mad
any Rex uh I just saw air I heard it's
great it's great it's so fun to watch it
really good it feels like a real movie
oh you would love it
for me I can't wait to watch it yeah I
just watched the Fable men's on your
wreck oh yeah that's good it's good it
takes a minute but it's great
Spielberg's movie The fablemans it's
like his life story oh yeah yeah it's
really good do you like it I didn't see
it yet oh you'll like it you told me it
was bad I had the first half took me a
second well once I got to the second
half I loved it I think it's good it's
good I'm watching a flight but it was uh
that got me yeah yeah I might be late on
this but beef is very good I hear it's
very good people are raving about beef
beef it's on Netflix yeah it's literally
no yeah there's a show uh he's just
recommending the food I thought he was
talking about the meat man I thought
that's a good bit
every week he's just like one week he's
like chicken is pretty good I like
chicken this week but well the way he
said it I'm kind of late on this
guys tune in next week salacus is going
to recommend fish that's crazy I got one
uh uh Briggs and Riley luggage I I'm all
out all my [__] is Briggs and Ryan it's
a lifetime guarantee it's expensive but
it's a lifetime what I bought a bag back
when I lived in L.A in like the early
2000s and it's like it was like 550
bucks which back then was a lot of money
for me yeah and uh give me an image it
was uh the great lifetime guarantee and
let me tell you something these guys
made a bad deal
yeah I've said it back like 10 times
because it got beat up people make
mistake of buying low end luggage and it
just breaks yeah I've had it break on me
yeah but then you buy one really good
one you have it for your [__] life
like uh I had a bag break at JFK airport
and I was like I'm [__] nothing I went
into a store they sell Briggs and Riley
bags whoa it cost me yeah it was like
something like five JFK was probably
yeah no it was it wasn't jacked up
really it wasn't that bad but it was
like man this is a great really even
when I was putting the stuff in I was
like wow this is like kind of sleeker
and better forever and honestly like I
just sent it back now and they don't
there's no verification I just send it
to them so I think it's not only
lifetime I think it's like if you have
kids you pass that down like that yeah
so till death sucks in relationships
it's great with materials yes so can I
go to a thrift store buy a Briggs and
Riley and send it in
I think when I got when I first sent it
in I had to tell where I bought it so I
don't know uh I could just lie say I
bought a JFK
I don't think that's gonna work Mark
don't be mad but I just don't think all
right
I'll try it but all right I gotta get
because everybody says to me to me I
always hear about two no tumi's good too
though I mean those a lot of companies
give uh I think tumi's way more
expensive oh but is it I got a guarantee
uh backpacks I don't think that's
guaranteed I don't think so either
there's one called Deer Creek or
something that's it's something like
that there's a lot of high-end companies
that are high that are lifetime but dogs
and Riley is legit for sure by the way
man the uh your bourbon's great thank
you nice job
online get that [__]
um why one drink of the Year Patagonia
also you send it in you got a torn
jacket they'll fix it for free really
yeah I got a torn uh send it in baby
really oh yeah they'll fix it all right
fun fact
it's just fun they just they just Bank
on no one sending it in
people are lazy you bank on laziness you
you might I'm [__] lazy dude oh yeah
I got a million subscriptions out there
and I've signed up for this and Audible
and all this other [__] still paying it
those people that tell you like those
you know you put in this you tell you
put in whatever how many uh
subscriptions you have on your phone and
yes holy [__] I should get that but I
also I'm like I'm [__] I can't even
get that they're banking on that they
know it
their sponsor
they're doing great and they're doing
great work and I love every second
pocket money we love your rocket money
it's a great concept rocket money you
guys are the real deal yeah you're
saving us love what you guys do hell
yeah should we plug dates let's do it
we're gonna be coming up Greg uh
on the road yeah yeah I'm on the road is
this coming out soon like when's it
coming out man mid-june something where
we're banking here but Mark's going to
Australia and I'm on the road for like
two weeks I yeah Nashville zany is in
the summer I'm trying to hit that one
and then the Ice House in L.A oh wow
trying to hit those great room when are
you in Zanies like sometime in I think
July oh yeah oh okay National in June
that would have been fun overlap yeah
man oh August oh you got Sunny videos
Bloomington
Pasadena Nashville Appleton Vegas
Chicago go see Greg Warren on the road
watch the salesman on uh YouTube yes
huge huge endorsement from all of us
here great special clean bring the kids
bring the kids and it's really just
quality joke right great stuff I'm all
over man yeah where am I going to be oh
yeah Denver second in Denver 23rd and
Santa Fe 24th in San Antonio adding a
bunch of [__] adding a bunch of [__]
look at that man Texas this Houston
Texas on the 25th
Alberta wow great on doors comedy taking
some time off there it looks like no
we're adding some stuff never uh we're
adding some stuff uh Montreal is going
to be added uh Columbus Theater in
Providence Rhode Island uh the Academy
of Music in Northampton uh Massachusetts
Higher Ground in Burlington Vermont and
uh in Albany we're gonna add as well and
then you know Toronto a lot of stuff's
coming
uh Cincy Columbus
uh Indianapolis
yeah that Egyptian Room in Indy is
really cool man is it yeah it's so big
though [__] Indie man yeah and he's a
weird area hard hard to get those you
guys are killing man I'm proud of you
guys
man a little OD eventually it's awesome
man Greg Warren Great comic definitely
definitely watch this special hell yeah
Hoyt Sherman in Des Moines yeah yeah man
you know it yeah all right you're the
one I love Des Moines yeah I've never
been there I got to go there oh it's fun
you gotta go to Des Moines man yeah so
yeah I'm after Australia I'm doing a big
theater tour we're going to paps in
Milwaukee give me some cities
just so I'm not there you go Milwaukee
Des Moines La San Diego Louisville
Kentucky Cincinnati Springfield
Cleveland
Cincinnati man yeah that was right where
right by Procter Gamble man oh wow dude
that's yeah Oklahoma City Dallas
Portland Cincinnati oh yeah Providence
Rhode Island Cleveland Grand Rapids
Denver uh Grand Junction Colorado
Hartford Connecticut all kinds of
denmarkdomencomedy.com mobile New
Orleans Santa Rosa when's the special
coming out Mark special comes
say horrible things so uh buckle up
should be fun and uh I don't do any of
these jokes that I did here so don't
worry about that and uh yeah we'll have
fun
I tweeted it I got about 11 likes it
yeah suck our pennies Mark yeah and also
also teas in New York November 4th um I
can't say the venue yet because they're
being sticklers but let's just say it's
in the theater where the [__] Knicks
play so you think about that really yeah
so just get ready [__] oh [__]
all right sounds good and we're the
field corn grows that's the old special
fish sandwich all right yeah what do you
have a new you have new material yet
ah man I got I got a
15 minute run or something yeah that's
where I'm at man I watched Nate the
other day he's got a new hour since his
thinking yeah he's unreal it's under the
monster man yeah I I gotta get with it I
gotta get going yeah it's tough it's
tough to build it's man it's like two
different jobs isn't it it's like
starting a special and then the ending
it or polishing it yeah well it's like
you're like throwing [__] the wall and
then like honing the [__] that yeah yeah
so it's uh it's way more fun to start
from scratch even though it's
frustrating because you will go to that
place where you get frustrated with the
crowd again yeah yourself it's not
pretty and but then when you're honing
You're just bored I'm trying to like I
have [__] that I know works now and I'm
trying to just like it's you get so
comfortable I can add this line but you
gotta just try new jokes step off the
diving board yeah but another better one
just starts gelling you're like oh I can
add that to this oh that'll finish that
you know that's really when it gets fun
but I'm not there yet no I'm not even
close yeah I'm like I don't I always
have this in like I don't know if I have
another one in me no I know I think the
same thing but you got it in there you
got it we all do but that's how you feel
after every
after every special it's a hangover it's
like you're like I'll never drink again
and then it's five or six pm you're like
I could have one yeah yeah you'll you'll
find a way great analogy thanks folks
get some Bodega get a shirt get a glass
we'll see in Hell praise Ella thank you
Greg thanks guys check out the special
the salesman on YouTube and uh Sally you
good all right Peters
there we go keep on keeping on
[Music]
in the same way
we might
be true
[Music]